Easter is it an incredibly exciting time
it's not a very important time for us
because it is one of the biggest-selling
Caesars we need to get Easter right
we're making around about 47 million
Easter eggs you know the whole year we
have around about 30% of the chocolate
markets at Easter time we have around
50% the best seller for us to use the
Cadbury Creme Egg the filled eggs we
make around about million of those with
1.2 million every single day a cream egg
is a solid milk chocolates Cadbury milk
chocolate and inside that you've got
fondant white fondant and obviously a
little bit of yellow fondant as well to
replicate sir what an egg looks like
they would just slam the two together
when we told a book mold and it closes
like a you're closing a book like most
chocolate manufacturing these days most
kids automated the easter eggs you'll be
eating and enjoying this Easter season
were made in the last where it could be
the last few weeks but it also could be
the last few months as well
whoo here we are at Easter 2014 each of
2015 is probably pretty much put to bed
in simpler planning and we're now
working on Easter 2016 a lot of people
think that cream egg is on sale all year
round it isn't
to me the cream egg is a little array of
spring sunshine in the dark days of
winter